rates of RSV or respiratory sensitial
virus have been surging since August
that's weeks earlier than the typical
season pediatric hospitals are pretty
stressed right now so doctors are
warning of a possible triple demig that
means cases of coveted fluent RSV a
virus that's been impacting children are
all expected to rise here's what to know
about the surge in RSV and what it means
for your winter
RSV is a virus spread through droplets
from coughing and sneezing and on
surfaces it's so common that nearly all
children come in contact with the virus
by the age of Two And while RSV feels
like a cold for most people it can be
severe for some infants and older adults
according to the CDC about 58 000
children under five are hospitalized due
to RSV every year in pre-coveted times
hospitalizations looked like this
peaking in January but in the first year
of the pandemic RSV rates flattened
that's because coveted safety measures
like distancing and face masks also
likely protected people from other
diseases but around the summer of 2021
cases of RSV shot up once you sort of
start mingling again and dropping those
restrictions you get a lot of cases
happening at one there's no approved
vaccine for RSV and children who didn't
get sick from the virus in 2020 or 2021
might have less immunity protection and
for this false surge there's a couple
things at play here one of them sort of
being that a lot of kids have gone back
to school in the fall and this year
there was significantly less masking in
a lot of schools and other safety
precautions that there were for the past
two years there's been less exposure
some of like the tiniest kids haven't
seen RSV before and so you have sort of
a higher susceptible population among
sort of the youngest this surgeon RSV
comes at a time when other respiratory
illnesses like the rhinovirus and
enteroviruses have increased
hospitalizations in children so doctors
are bracing for more cases the
Connecticut Children's Medical Center in
Hartford is considering setting up a
field Hospital in case things get worse
and some Physicians are worried about
precautionary measures for high risk
infants vulnerable babies as a
precaution and get injections of this
monoclonal antibody during the normal
respiratory season but if you know RSV
strikes earlier or during the summer
like a lot of those babies unless
hospitals sort of can anticipate and
keep up quickly sort of lose that extra
protection it's not just RSV the flu
season arrived earlier than usual this
year too there is a lack of exposure
because less people have had it for the
past two seasons
um lower vaccination rates because you
know if that's a sort of a better way to
build up exposure less precautions as
people are heading inside and into
schools and workplaces again and that
combined with a possible uptick in covet
cases has doctors worried about a triple
threat of RSV covid and flu a Confluence
of all of these viruses could put
hospitals under serious strain this
winter because we're the last two
Winters hospitals were completely
slammed entirely just with covid what we
saw during the pandemic is that if a
hospital is overrun it's harder to get
in for any other sort of care that you
might need an overwhelmed Hospital isn't
good for anybody to help reduce Hospital
capacity Health officials are
encouraging people to get their flu and
covet vaccines